look we're all still dealing with a
strange time in our nation and uh
i i it it seems like last night wasn't
as troubling as the night before and
hopefully we are in a position where
the things that are causing
real concern the rioting the looting the
potential for violence that that will
subside
that that that shouldn't change the
topic away from the the fundamental
issue which is hopefully we have arrived
at a moment
where there will be meaningful change as
it relates to the manner in which law
enforcement officials interact with
african americans and people of color
that is the
that is the message that colin
kaepernick first tried to send four
years ago that is the message that still
resonates today chris and we spent a lot
of time talking about it yesterday today
we're just going to spend one segment on
it but there are some important
developments that we need to share and
this trend of quarterbacks speaking out
has continued and uh you know some some
of the most important players in the nfl
chiming in yesterday russell wilson the
seahawks quarterback adding his voice to
the mix a lengthy statement that we have
uh
posted in its entirety at
profootballtalk.com
you can see it there you can see it at
russell wilson's twitter feed my hide
hurt my heart hurts pain frustration
outrage sadness and it goes on from
there and a very good statement from him
a powerful statement also from patrick
mahomes the chiefs quarterback chris and
and look
whether it's white quarterbacks or
african-american quarterbacks the
quarterbacks are the leaders yesterday
we talked about how so many white
quarterbacks have spoken out and we
shared the comments from richard sherman
the 49ers cornerback who explained how
powerful it is when white voices add
their voices to this situation but the
quarterbacks are the leaders of the team
they are the most identifiable
and most popular players in the league
generally especially guys like russell
wilson and patrick mahomes it's just
good to see more voices joining what
hopefully becomes an avalanche for
change that that it's undeniable that
change is needed that's what i hope we
get to the point where so many people
are saying this is unacceptable what it
needs to change
that change becomes a foreground
conclusion well yeah i mean it is i mean
come on the country's in a bad spot it's
got to change what's gone on the last
four or five years really come on it's
been longer than that uh just you know
just in in a lot of our african-american
communities and things like that
it's not easy for them their struggles
and of course yes white america is not
making it easier and you know you said
it mike you know guys like patrick
mahomes he's he's the best player in
football white black it doesn't matter
it means something when he releases a
statement like that along with russell
wilson now the big thing to me too at
some point just you know i do think that
the next phase of this so we don't
revisit this topic six months from now
again or seven months ago you know i
think i do think some people some
players are gonna have to get on like
the front line a little bit and start
really putting faces with some of these
statements and things like that to show
that hey
you know we're here for change things
got to change and i'm russell wilson or
patrick mahomes or joe burrow or
whatever it is and i'm here with the
people to let you know that it's not
right and i think that time's coming too
because i just think there's too many
nfl players right now that are
distraught and angry uh about this
situation and you know in the way in
which america is kind of going right now
well and i i think it's it's not just
incumbent on the players it's incumbent
on others in positions of power and
influence and some people want it to
only be politicians i think that changes
by the time the politicians follow the
lead of the people and the most
prominent voices among the people are
the ones who need to be speaking up and
there have been
a handful of coaches who have spoken up
now this is where it gets a little bit
dicey because brian flores issues
a clear written statement that left no
doubt where the dolphins coach stands on
this issue and it raises some very
thought-provoking content as to
the way some people reacted to colin
kaepernick and the way some people
quietly
uh reacted to the murder of george floyd
frank reich had a statement that he read
to reporters yesterday anthony lynn made
comments to jim trotter of nfl media
matt nagy did some media appearances
yesterday the bears coach had some
things to say
um
there was a kevin stefanski statement
that was part of a much broader
joint cleveland browns columbus crew
statement and and uh and those are the
voices we've seen in some capacity
publicly but
i assume every coach is dealing with
this in some way shape or form pete
carroll the seahawks coach
basically turned the floor over
yesterday during what right otherwise
would have been a virtual
meeting aimed at getting ready for the
season to talk through these issues and
and uh and that's good too look
privately
within the conference
it's important it's important to do that
um and i think it's also important and
it's an opportunity when when their
voices are made public for the rest of
us to say here's a recognizable name and
face and voice who is adding to the
chorus that change is needed that that's
my broader point the more people that we
look at on tv and we recognize and we
respect that say change is needed the
harder it comes it becomes for those who
don't want change to resist change so uh
so look it's good that it's happening
privately i'm hoping that more will join
in publicly and we'll see how yeah right
chris no no i know you're right we need
everybody to jump in publicly again
that's what i don't like about this
conversation something you just said a
minute ago you know where people are
trying to say oh let the politicians
handle this you know no screw that this
is a humanity effort this has nothing to
do with politics this is about treating
people the right way it's about not
discriminating against certain people of
color and things like that so it's a
real issue in our country and you know
it doesn't even matter yes i i you know
first off i could sit here and speak
just my time at texas mike i know i've
told stories but just for people to
think it's not real is ridiculous you
know people used to yell to me go back
to you know the north you yankee because
of the way i was dressed you know people
would i would wear a jersey you know and
dress like i guess you know what they
thought was like a black guy and they
would tell me they would yell at me hey
sims you're white like yeah i know thank
you i look in the mirror every day but
it just tells you that those issues are
real in our country and lastly mike i
just want to say how cool it is that i
think pete carroll does that with the
seattle seahawks it's what makes them a
special organization it's what makes
them play so hard for him uh it's what
makes players want to go to seattle and
play in that organization because they
continue to show that their players you
know don't have to be robots and can
have voices and personalities and care
about people so i think that is you know
something that a part of the culture
that pete carroll deserves a lot of
credit for john schneider along with
along with him uh for setting that forth
and on a day where it's hard to go to
work and study on football plays for a
lot of guys yeah air it out because this
is this is a human rights personal issue
and i think it deserves talking
and and there has been chris a range of
statements and comments some stronger
than others
uh some that just really grab your
attention and and the seahawks issued a
statement yesterday that that struck me
in the same way that the statement from
raiders owner mark davis that we shared
with everyone yesterday struck me it
because it calls the situation what it
is it doesn't sugarcoat it it doesn't
inflame
but it is candid it has the kind of
blunt frank approach that i think we
need right now to ensure that people
don't forget this moment when it fades
and and inevitably and hopefully the
violent aspect of this will fade but we
still remember why change is needed the
seahawks family is dismayed by the
unacceptable act of violence that
occurred against george floyd last week
in minneapolis and grieve that loss
along with countless others in a similar
manner including most recently brianna
taylor and ahmad arbury our heartfelt
condolences are extended to their
families and every other family that has
had to endure the pain from similar
atrocities
these biased actions
are systemic and have plagued our
society for generations and have
culminated to the current state of
unrest we are experiencing that's the
statement from the seahawks that's just
part of it but that's what that's what
grab that
to
to really inspire
all the way down to the average citizen
who may not even be paying that much
attention to this to get their attention
and inspire them to say this has to
change that's the kind
of clarity
that must create
from the top
and and uh that's that's another reason
to apply the seahawks for how they've
handled this chris no doubt no no
tiptoeing you know that's that that's
again it kind of fits within the theme
of the seattle seahawks they're not a
tiptoe type team you know they handle
confrontation head-on they're not
worried about being political or maybe
offending that white racist fan they had
that or they're worried about oh he
might go buy a hat later we don't want
to offend him no the hell with that guy
he needs to hear it from people like
pete carroll in the seattle seahawks
maybe that'll change him you know so
that's where you know i really really
applaud mark davis and the seattle
seahawks for coming out with those type
of comments that are strong yeah there's
no wiggle room
it it gets right to the root of the
problem it points it out it throws it in
our face and says we got to do something
about it and to me that's the type of
action that needs to be taken
taken right now
and look sometimes the statements will
spur others to act and some of these
teams are also initiating action
themselves the new orleans saints and
pelicans both owned by gail benson
statements are words she said yesterday
unified action towards a solution is
what needs to come from this now the two
franchises formed a social justice
leadership coalition saints linebacker
demario davis pelicans guard lonzo ball
and j.j redick will be on that that
coalition and that that is
that is another tangible way and and you
know we're all looking for ways that we
can get involved ways that we can help
and and i think that when the
organizations the public organizations
that are
are known to people who are sports fans
when they start finding ways to do
things maybe that also becomes
inspiration chris for the rest of us to
find ways to do things
yeah well i i don't think there's any
doubt about that you know i mean again
and i think it just we need more people
to come forward more powerful people
more players more faces be put to this
conversation and it can't be is
something that you know we die it dies
out and we lose passion for you know
four or five weeks from now when this
kind of the death the dust all settles
from this this is a fight that we got to
keep you know pushing forward moving
forward continue to break those barriers
with with people who you know just just
don't understand what's going on in this
country and continue to have that
conversation for for people who are
sheltered in life who don't get to be
around a lot of different people
different cultures and skin colors and
whatever it may be
you know
they sometimes lack the experiences and
things like that to know what you know
these people are which is great people
and uh yeah again i i applaud the nfl
here
all coaches players a lot of the owners
doing the right thing right now we just
got to keep fighting the good fight and
keep moving forward with it
dolphins coach brian flores walking the
talk as well taking time out from a
monday that would have been should have
been devoted to preparations for the
season he and general manager chris
greer and team president tom garfinkel
spent time actually loading groceries
into the trunks of vehicles for people
in the miami area who are in need of
food so you know it's not just the
statement it's getting out there and
doing things and providing that symbol
of doing things so all the more reason
to credit the dolphins and coach flores
for how they've handled these troubling
times in our country
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports